on his first brief visit to Haiti as the
U.N Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
said the ongoing crisis and violence
could only be sorted with much more help
from the International Community he told
reporters that included providing an
international Force to re-establish
security
we discussed
and we are in full agreement about the
needs for the International Community
through the security Council and through
a number of countries that will provide
the necessary forces for the
International Community to come in
support to the police the Asian police
not only in training and Equipment but
also with the presence of a security
Force able to dismantle the activity of
the gangs from the air the Haitian
Capital Porter Prince looks spectacular
but on the ground it's extremely
dangerous the people suffering from
hunger and instability at the mercy of
the gangs who control much of the city
the Haitian police are outgunned and
have little control what the Secretary
General is proposing is an international
paramilitary police strike force but no
country has agreed to take the lead role
a subject he dodged when asked about it
at the news conference by Al Jazeera the
leadership will not be a very
International
Force the leadership will always be of
the Asian police the head of the un's
children's agency Catherine Russell also
recently visited Haiti and she told me
she was shocked by what she saw it's
terrible actually it was kind of
shockingly bad and I you know had read
everything I knew how how difficult the
situation was I knew that children were
suffering there from malnutrition and
other things but the violence was was
palpable there and I think that it's
it's a terrible place right now for
children and the the Securities the
security situation is something that we
all should be worried about
the secretary General's visit was short
for security reasons it lasted less than
eight hours but he is the highest level
visitor for some considerable time his
aim to get the world to take more
interest in what the UN believes is
becoming a forgotten country James Bay's
Al Jazeera of the United Nations